[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAVITHA GOPALAKRISHNAN:
Before we get started,
let's take a quick look at
the evolution of the cloud
landscape.
I know that this has
been the buzzword,
so to speak, since the
last several years now.
If you look here, you'll
see that as we started
this migration to the
cloud, it started out
in a bunch of different flavors.
So there were combinations
of hybrid cloud,
which is part on-premise.
And then part of your workload's
residing in the cloud.
Then there were
also public cloud.
There was private cloud.
Of course, due to security
and other reasons,
there were a lot of
enterprise companies
that preferred starting
out their cloud
journey with the private cloud
instead of a public cloud.
But what we can see here is
that over the last three years,
of all of these different
combinations that we just
talked about, the public
cloud is the only one
that's been growing.
So we've been seeing an
increasing trend of enterprises
wanting to move more and more
of their workloads to the cloud.
We'll be talking about some
of the benefits, of course.
But in general, at
a high level, this
is, of course, because
of the flexibility
that a public cloud
brings to the fore.
So you don't really have to
worry about the management
aspect of it.
You don't have to worry
about things like scaling
up, scaling down, failover,
disaster recovery, things
like that.
And as we evolve, we expect
to see more enterprises
wanting to leverage these
capabilities that are all
provided by public clouds.
If we take another
step in this direction,
again, we're looking at
the industry trends here.
You'll see that the
top couple of reasons
or the top couple of projects
that enterprises are really
investing in are optimizing
their existing cloud use.
So this is companies
that have already
invested in the public
cloud to some extent,
but they just want
to optimize more.
Again, this may be for cost
savings or other motivations
as well.
And then there
are companies that
are starting to move more
and more of their workloads
to the cloud.
Databases, of course, are very
central to cloud migrations.
But as you know, they're
also really tough.
And this is due to a number
of different reasons.
So we're going to take
apart maybe a couple
of the top reasons.
The first one is,
of course, there's
a lot of proprietary
technology and functionality
that's built into a lot of the
legacy database technologies.
So if we talk about Oracle--
I'm just using that as a
frame of reference here--
that may be things
like stored procedure,
custom functions, Oracle
RAC, so on and so forth.
So this makes it
really hard for you
to migrate to an equivalent
cloud-native technology.
The second one is, of course,
your historical on-prem
databases are all
pretty monolithic.
So these are humongous
servers which don't really
fit into the cloud way
of doing things, right?
So oftentimes,
again, if you take
this huge, monolithic
server, you
have to split it up into
multiple servers in the cloud.
And the third thing,
which a lot of companies
actually maybe underestimate,
is the reliance
of applications on databases.
So if you think about a
company that's been around for,
let's say, 10, 15
years, as your business
grows, you have
hundreds or thousands
of apps, both internal- and
external-facing applications,
that are all relying
on the database.
So as you're thinking
about migration,
it's really important for you
to consider the risks that
are associated as
you're migrating these
to different cloud
technologies and obviously
trying to minimize your
exposure as you do this.
So because of all of
these complexities
that we talked about,
we see two general types
of database migrations.
So there's a
homogeneous migration,
which is also commonly
known as lift and shift,
where you're retaining
the same database engine,
but you're just moving over
from on-premise to the cloud.
While this does bring some
benefits, like, for example,
you already have
a trained-up staff
that understands the technology,
that's really familiar with it.
And so there's not as
much of a learning curve
associated with it
as you're migrating
the stack over to the cloud.
So that, by itself, extends into
faster migration time as well.
And like I said, in this case,
because the database engine is
still the same, you have
fewer application rewrites,
which, of course, means
that, in some cases,
you might have lower risk.
Now, that being said, there
are also some challenges
that we briefly talked about
in the previous slide, which
is server sizing
and configuration.
Like I said, if you're talking
about huge, monolithic servers,
moving this to an
equivalent way in the cloud
is going to be really tough.
So you have to
think about how you
can split up this huge server
into multiple different
servers.
The other type of migration is
called heterogeneous migration.
People commonly also use
this in the same vein
as modernization or
digital transformation,
which is essentially saying
that, OK, I want to port
over my database engine.
I've already invested a
lot in these licenses.
And the cost of
maintaining those licenses
is actually going up
with every passing year.
And as my business
grows, I'm actually
building a lot more
applications on top of that.
So what that means
is that you're
saying that, OK, I'm going
to make a business decision
to invest more in the cloud.
And I'm going to do
what I need to do
to actually make it fit into
the cloud way of doing things.
Now, some of the
benefits for this--
we commonly see cost
savings, or lowering our TCO
is one huge thing that we see.
The second thing is also
reducing your reliance
on a particular technology.
As we've seen the
evolution of public cloud,
there are more and more
open-source-based technologies.
So we're going to talk about
Postgres today and a little bit
about MySQL as well.
And we see this across
the database spectrum--
not just in the
relational world,
but a lot in the
non-relational world as well.
So by moving to
these technologies,
you're actually
lowering your reliance
on a particular
vendor, as well as
the proprietary
technology that comes
from that particular vendor.
And then, of course,
because you're in the cloud,
it makes it a lot easier for you
to scale up and down as needed
so that you don't have to have
reserved capacity at all times.
So if you're a retailer who's
thinking about peak season
times, like Black Friday
sales, or Christmas holidays,
or something like
that, you don't really
need to hold on to that capacity
for the rest of the year.
You can scale up
and down as needed.
And you don't really
have to worry about that.
The other thing is, of course,
failover and disaster recovery.
Instead of investing
in your own data center
and maintaining them
all around the year,
you can actually offload
that to the cloud provider.
And as we move into the
cloud way of architecting
our applications, of
course, more and more
companies want to just take
care of the innovation piece--
the things that truly help
you derive business insight
and value instead of
things like, how do I
manage my infrastructure?
How do I manage my database?
How do I configure this?
They don't really want
to get into the business
of doing that.
And they would rather
have the public cloud
provider take care of that.
Of course, some
challenges with this--
it's going to be a
more complex, probably
longer migration effort.
And when you're moving from
one database technology
to another one, you also
have to be mindful of things
like schema conversion.
Another thing that
we talked about
was, especially if you're
talking about production grid
applications, you have to make
sure that there's no data loss.
So that's where your
real-time change data capture
comes into play,
making sure that you
are able to migrate
your data in real time
instead of doing it in batches.
So these are the challenges
that we typically see.
So now, I'll hand
it over to David
to take us through the key
steps that are involved
in any database migration.
And then we'll get
into the details,
specifically from migrating
your databases from Oracle
to Postgres.
DAVID YAHALOM:
Thank you, Kavitha.
KAVITHA GOPALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
DAVID YAHALOM: So every
database migration project
is complicated,
specifically when
it comes to heterogeneous
database migrations,
because as Kavitha
mentioned, there
are challenges which
we can overcome,
but there are challenges.
And what you see here is kind
of like taking a database
migration project and
breaking it down to,
I would say, the
six primary steps.
And we're going to go
through each one of them,
talk about some of
the, I would say,
areas that you should
be made aware of,
some of the tips and
recommendations we can share.
From our experience,
as I said, we
have done countless
heterogeneous database
migrations, both
on-prem and off-prem,
and of course, obviously,
on-prem to the cloud.
So we would love to share
this experience with you.
So let's go over the steps,
starting with assessment
and source discovery.
So this is extremely
important, because it's
the first step in your
database migration journey.
You need to start
by understanding
what you currently have in
your existing environment.
Specifically, this
talk is about Oracle
to Postgres migrations, the
Cloud SQL Postgres migration.
But this is also applicable
when you change database engines
from other source and
target technologies.
Understanding the source
environment, what you currently
have running right now,
the layout and structure
of your Oracle databases
before you even
start the migration
might seem like trivial.
But it's super important.
And that's because a lot
of the features which
you may be using right
now in your Oracle
database, your
high-availability configuration,
you may be using Oracle
React or Data Guard.
You might be using some
proprietary features.
So you need to be made aware
of these before you start
your migration so you can plan
to mitigate any, I would say,
functionality that might
be missing in Postgres that
you're currently using in Oracle
by leveraging other Google
Cloud technologies-- and we
see some examples of that--
or sometimes, even by writing
custom application code.
So that's the first
thing that you
need to do when it comes
to database assessment
and migration.
You also need to be
able to determine,
when you do your
migrations to Google Cloud,
and specifically when you
choose cloud-native database
technologies, such as
Postgres and/or MySQL,
you also need to make a decision
which database engine is
better for you.
That's because a lot
of the functionality
that you may have-- sorry,
I just escaped the slide.
A lot of the functionality that
you may have in your source
Oracle database might only be
available in MySQL or Postgres.
And we're going to talk
about that as well,
as well as some tools,
and products, and tips
that can help you make
the right decision.
So assessment and source
discovery is very important.
You'll need to
review your database
configuration, your schema,
your database sizing.
As Kavitha said, very
large, monolithic databases
might need special attention
when it comes to migrations.
You need to make sure
and see if you're
using any proprietary features.
You need to take a look
at your database workload,
because some of your--
because as you know,
applications which
were developed
to run on an Oracle database
might use some Oracle-specific
SQL syntax.
Or even when it comes to--
if all of your applications
support other database engines,
such as Postgres, your workload
might behave differently.
So performance tuning
is also an aspect.
And we're going to
talk all about that.
But assessment and
source discovery
is extremely,
extremely important.
Also, as shown on
this slide, you
have to understand what
applications connect
to your database,
because when you
move a database to the cloud,
you're saying, you know what?
I'm going to move my Oracle
database to Cloud SQL Postgres,
for example.
You need to make sure you
understand which applications
connect the database.
Can these applications
be ported to Postgres?
Maybe they are
compatible with Postgres.
If you have legacy
applications, it's
going to be a much more
challenging migration
process than if your
applications are relatively
modern.
So the assessment
and source discovery
is very, very, very important.
And there are two ways
to actually do that.
So the old-fashioned
way of figuring out
what you have running
right now-- you
might have a CMDB
database somewhere.
But drilling down to
the actual databases,
understanding what are the
features that you have,
the configuration,
what high-availability
infrastructure you
have in place--
you can either do it
by running scripts--
you know, SQL scripts.
And you have a bunch
of code that you
can run on the
database to detect what
are the features are using.
You can query the
Oracle Data dictionary
for understanding what
schema objects you use.
You can query the
Oracle AWR repository
to understand what's
the workload running
in the database.
But we also want to
talk about the product
that we have developed.
As I said, we've been doing
these database migrations
for a long period of
time, which kind of takes
all of our experience
and puts it
in a product that can
automate the assessment
and discovery for you.
And that's migVisor, which
I'm going to show you a demo.
migVisor for Google Cloud,
which we are officially
launching today, is
a custom-made product
built for Google Cloud, which
can scan your existing Oracle
environment and help you create
your migration plan, show you
what databases you have
running, their configuration,
the proprietary
features, show you
the migration complexity
for both Postgres and MySQL
running in GCP.
And we'll see a live demo,
which I think is very cool.
But that's a-- we
think, at least,
that's the reason
we created migVisor.
It's a much faster
way and a better way
to start off your migration
journey, instead of having
to do everything manually.
And as I mentioned previously,
it's also extremely important
when you start your migration,
before you actually--
and we'll talk about it in the
next steps in the migration
process--
but before you start
converting your schema
and moving your data
and kind of decide--
actually implementing
the migration itself.
You have to choose
between-- if you're
going to leverage
cloud-native technologies,
if you're going to
leverage Google Cloud SQL,
if you're going to leverage
open-source database
engine, you have to choose
between Postgres and MySQL,
which, again, depending on the
specific proprietary Oracle
features you're using, the
types of schema objects
that you'll have, Postgres or
MySQL might be a better fit.
And again, our
product, migVisor can
help you make that decision,
as you'll see in a moment.
But again, this is
an important step
you have to take into account.
In addition to the structure
of your source database
and the compatibility of
certain schema objects,
you also have to kind
of take into account
if your IT staff is more
familiar with Postgres
or MySQL.
These are the
non-technical requirements.
But they're also very important.
And also, your
applications-- so if you're
moving your database and
its application to GCP,
you're going to leverage Cloud
SQL Postgres, for example.
But the applications
that run on this database
right now happen to
be, I don't know,
support both Oracle and MySQL.
So maybe MySQL will
be the better option.
So also, you have to
take that into account
as you start planning
your migration journey.
So there are-- on
the technical aspects
of choosing between
Postgres and MySQL--
and again, this talk is
mostly focused on Postgres.
But it's still something
that's important to mention.
So, as I said, there
are schema objects
that you might be using
right now in Oracle
or features that you might be
using right now in your Oracle
database that are supported
in either MySQL and Postgres.
You see some examples here, such
as sequences, which are only
supported in Postgres,
user-defined types, which
are only supported in Postgres.
But virtual columns,
on the other hand,
have better support in MySQL.
Partitions, for
example, Postgres 10
is the first version
of Postgres that
added declarative
partitioning support.
Postgres 11 expands on that.
But MySQL always had a
partitioning mechanism
that more closely resembles what
you originally had in Oracle.
So there are differences.
And it's very important to
kind of keep that in mind.
And this is just a few of them.
There are a bunch more.
And again, we're going to
show you in migVisor demo
how it can help you-- how our
product can help you identify
those features and
kind of tell you, hey,
so this database
might be better suited
to run on Cloud SQL Postgres,
while that database might
be more compatible
with Cloud SQL MySQL.
So again, just keep that in
mind as you start your migration
journey.
So migVisor for Google
Cloud, which, again, we
are launching today, is meant
to automate your source target
discovery and assessment phase.
It detects your database
configuration, your schema
configuration, the schema
object that you're using.
It gives you an
overview of, hey, this
is your existing Oracle fleet.
These are the proprietary
features that you're using.
These are the schema
objects that you're using,
and then assigns a migration
compatibility score, migration
complexity score, to both
Cloud SQL MySQL and Cloud SQL
Postgres, as well
as, by the way,
if you just plan to run
Postgres on a Compute Engine.
So there are also
differences there,
which we'll talk
about in a moment.
So it's meant to automate this
process and kind of give you,
in a very visual way, a lot
of insights, and metrics,
and dashboards that are
relevant for a migration process
before you even start migrating
a single database, which
is, again, super important.
You don't want to
start a migration
and then, as you go through
it, kind of realize, oh, wow,
we forgot that this application
connects the database once
a quarter to run a report.
And it's not compatible
with Postgres.
So that puts a
stick in our wheels.
Or oh, wow, we have
so many synonyms.
We have like over
100,000 synonyms
in our database, which--
we have syn databases that
have such excessive
number of synonyms.
And that's not
supported in Postgres.
So what do we do?
Should we create
views as a workaround?
So all of that is kind
of presented in migVisor.
Our product has two components.
So it has the web console.
It's a SaaS product.
So you have the
web console, where
you see all of our
migration insights, all
of the details about
your environment,
so we can explore and
see how your migration is
going to look like.
And also, we have a very
small standalone component
known as the migVisor
Metadata Collector, which
is a standalone Java utility.
You need to download and run
it on a server in your existing
environment.
It can even be your laptop.
You do not need to install
it on the database itself.
Our Metadata Collector,
what it basically does
is connects-- opens a JDBC
connection to your existing
fleet of Oracle databases.
It can connect to thousands
of databases in one go.
So it supports analyzing
your databases in parallel,
runs a bunch of queries, queries
the Oracle Data dictionary,
queries the Oracle metadata
tables, the Oracle AWR
repository, gathers all
of the information that's
needed for the
migration analysis,
and then creates a local
ZIP file, encrypted, which
you upload to our console.
And then, boom.
You see all of the
migration insights.
So that's kind of the
architecture for our product.
And we created it so
it would be extremely
easy and simple to use.
Again, you don't need
to install anything
on your source databases.
You only need one
Metadata Collector,
no matter how many Oracle
databases you want to analyze.
And we see our users, when you
want to analyze your Oracle
environment for Cloud SQL
migrations for GCP migrations,
we see them being able
to-- from start to end,
from actually being able to
access the migration insights,
it's a matter of minutes, OK?
And traditionally,
if you were to do
this using scripts, and running
and creating spreadsheets
and Word documents, kind
of mapping your existing
environment and trying to figure
out which application connects
to what database, and
what are the complexities,
it would obviously take
much longer than that.
Sometimes it's days,
minimum, sometimes even
weeks for a large fleet
of Oracle databases.
So before the demo, just
a couple of-- a few other
slides I want to
talk to you about.
So essentially, all of
our migration insights,
all of our metrics, everything
that we kind of show
and surface in migVisor,
it all boils down
to a migration score.
So we basically give each
database in your environment
a score from 0 to 100,
depending on how complex it is.
So I just want to show a
couple of examples of--
two examples of how the
low-complexity database
for migration would look
like versus a high-complexity
database.
And you'll see more
in the live demo.
So for example, we have an
easy migration database,
an easy database to migrate.
So this is an Oracle
database that has,
of course, some
proprietary features.
It has some Oracle-specific
schema objects.
It makes sense.
I mean, it would be rare
to see a production Oracle
database that just has a bunch
of tables and indexes, right?
So the features that we
detected in this database,
such as a job scheduler,
inter-region Data Guard,
certain tables and data types,
some functions or procedures,
indexes--
all of those aspects have
compatibility with, say,
Postgres as a target platform.
So the migration
score would be low.
And it would even--
when we kind of show you
our migration insights,
we'll even give you tips, what
we call migration tips, on,
hey, you're using Oracle Job
Scheduler to maybe run jobs
in your database on
a reoccurring basis.
There are alternatives
you can use.
So we're going to show you--
maybe use Apache
Airflow, for example.
So we're going to show you
that in our product as well.
So it's very cool.
And again, this
is just an example
of a low-complexity database.
We also look, by the way, at the
stored procedure code and kind
of trying to figure out if you
have any usage of propriety
Oracle DBMS packages,
UTL packages, certain SQL
syntax that might be only
compatible with Oracle,
such as a connect-by
expression, which might not
be supported fully.
So again, a very easy
database to migrate.
On the other hand,
there will also
be databases which
would be more difficult.
In a big Oracle
environment, you'll
see a mix of low-complexity
and high-complexity databases.
That is expected.
But you want to be made
aware of that beforehand.
And maybe that's how
you can prioritize
which databases
you're going to move
to cloud-native
open-source technologies
and which databases
you might want to do
as a lift-and-shift project.
So here is a more
complex database.
So it's a React database, which
would require rearchitecting
your database for
deployment, because you're
using an active ActiveCluster.
It has a lot of database scenes.
So you can have multiple stored
procedures or SQL queries
where you're manually
influencing the behavior
of the Oracle optimizer.
So that would probably indicate
that performance tuning
when you move to Postgres,
with its query planner, which
would probably run
those SQLs differently,
would require a big effort.
So that's another thing
you need to keep in mind.
It has synonyms, which are
not supported progress.
But we will tell you, hey,
maybe move this to views.
Migrate them to views.
It has user directories.
So you're probably
accessing files
from the operating system
from within the database.
So that would require,
again, maybe moving
to Google Cloud Storage.
Database links, same.
So what are you going to do?
You currently have this Oracle
database accessing other Oracle
databases.
So you need to
keep that in mind.
Maybe you cannot move
this database in vacuum.
And you need to maybe move a
bunch of databases together.
And again, usage of DBMS and
UTL proprietory Oracle APIs
inside your stored procedures,
multiple partitioned tables--
some of them might
be hash partitioning,
which is not supported-- only
supported in Postgres 11,
if I remember correctly.
Fast refresh materialized views,
complex queries-- so again,
just an example of how would
a high-complexity database
for migration would look like.
And the benefit is that
you'll be able to determine,
if you have multiple
Oracle databases, which
are the ones that
are going to be
the quick wins, the low-hanging
fruits, the ones you can get
maybe migrating to Cloud SQL,
Postgres, and MySQL relatively
easily.
So let's maybe do a quick
demo of our product,
just to show you
migVisor in live action.
So if you can switch
to my computer, please,
that would be fantastic.
There we go.
So this is our login screen.
Again, it's a SaaS product.
When you log in,
the first thing we
show you is a
high-level overview
of your current environment,
such as how many databases
have you actually
analyzed using migVisor.
This is just a very
small demo environment.
The server sizings,
number of CPU cores--
we also show you the comparative
migration complexity.
Here, you can see
for running Postgres
and Compute, versus
Cloud SQL Postgres,
versus Cloud SQL MySQL.
We also show you,
again, depending
on the target that you choose,
a very high-level overview
of the specific
complexity per database.
But we do surface
a lot more details.
This is just like a
high-level overview
of your existing
environments so you
will know what you're dealing
with before you dig deeper.
And then I think
the coolest feature
is that you can actually
simulate your migration
before you actually perform it.
So say we're interested
in moving Oracle
to Cloud SQL Postgres.
That's what we're interested in.
So we choose the source
and target combination.
We click on Analyze.
Then you can choose some of
all of our database server.
Click on Analyze.
And the first screen we see
is a very high-level screen
that even if you're not
a database administrator,
and you just have no database
background, what we do
is rank your databases based
on migration complexity,
from lowest to highest.
So without even digging deeper,
which we'll see in a second,
I know that they have databases
where the migration complexity
is going to be very low.
So maybe here is my POC.
Here is my prototype database
for heterogeneous migration,
versus other
databases, where it's
going to be more complicated.
So it doesn't mean that
we cannot migrate them.
It just means it's
probably going to be
a more challenging process.
It's often worthwhile, but
just surfacing those details
beforehand.
Clicking on each one
of those databases,
that's where you start to
see the verbose information.
So each one of those bars
is, of course, clickable.
And you can also
kind of show all
of the databases in one screen.
And then, we actually--
this is where
we present all of the
individual features
that we have detected in
each one of the source
databases that can make
your migration easy or more
difficult.
We also show you some
server-related information
for sizing.
Here are all the features
that we have detected.
So this is, for example,
a record database.
It has 103 database scenes.
And it'll actually show
you the schema name
and the actual
procedure name where
we found the database scenes.
It has over 1,000
synonyms, and so on.
As you see, our list of the
features that we detect,
which is over 100 different
features in Oracle,
is quite extensive.
And we also flag those features
based on the migration impact--
high, medium, and low.
So it also takes into
account the number
of usages for a feature.
So it's not just, hey, we
found usage of Oracle's DBMS
random package.
It's because we found
only one usage of it.
So even if you have to manually
code an equivalent for DBMS
random or use the
Postgres equivalent,
it's not going to
be that difficult.
But if this was like, I don't
know, 1,000 occurrences,
then it might be a little
bit more difficult.
And we also provide
those migration tooltips.
So when you click on this
little eye icon next to each one
of the features that we detect,
we show you a small, short,
and to-the-point tooltip
of saying, why is this--
why was this feature flagged?
Is it going to be a problem?
Yes or no?
How can you walk around
anything that's not supported?
And you also provide links
to the actual Cloud SQL
documentation.
So, for example, for synonyms,
you'll see, clicking on it
will just say, hey.
So synonyms were detected.
However, they are not supported.
You can use views or maybe the
set search path in your queries
as a workaround.
And, again, we try to
provide this information
for each one of the features
that we detect, provide
multiple alternatives
if possible,
just so you'll know
that before you actually
start your migration.
We also provide the ability
to do schema-based analysis.
So you can exclude
certain schemas
from your migration analyses.
Let's say you want to peel
off individual schemas
and move them to GCP.
We also kind of help you
perform target sizing.
So we show you the memory,
IO, and CPU requirement
for each schema, which can
be, again, very useful,
because we see a use
case where people
take these monolithic
Oracle databases
and break them up, split them up
to smaller Cloud SQL instances.
We also show you a list
of all of the applications
that connect to the database.
That's so you won't
forget any application
when you do the migration.
If there is this reporting
tool that connects once
in a quarter, but generates
a report for a CEO,
it's super critical.
But that's a legacy application
written in Oracle Hyperion
BI, something that's not
compatible with more modern
cloud-native technologies.
You want to be
made aware of that.
We also show you--
we do a workload
analysis on the
database, showing you
on a per-schema level
and per-instance level,
is this an OLTP database,
an analytics database,
the ratio between OLTP and
analytics queries per schema.
Maybe BigQuery would be a better
alternative for certain schemas
where the workload is
predominantly analytics.
So we show you this information.
We kind of surface that.
We also show you database
links, schema dependencies.
So again, all of
this information
is meant for you
to understand what
you're dealing with before you
actually start your migration
process.
We also flag OCI applications
that connect to the database
so that you'll know if
your application mixes
modern or legacy.
And again, we
encourage you to use--
so migVisor GCP is
going to be made
available in the
marketplace soon.
Right now, if you
want to use it,
you can reach out to Kavitha.
And we do encourage
you to use migVisor
for Google Cloud as the first
step in your migration process.
We think it's very valuable
and can save you a lot of time.
And we tried to just take
our experience and kind of--
from database
migrations and kind
of turn that into a product.
So that's migVisor.
If you can please maybe
switch back to the deck.
There we go.
So that's database
assessments for you.
Again, it's the first step.
And we encourage you
to put effort into it
so that you will
basically know what you're
dealing with before you
actually start the migration
process itself.
The second step is
success criteria.
So it might seem like trivial.
But it's actually
very, very important.
There are multiple steps.
When you actually start
migrating your database,
converting your database,
there are multiple steps
you have to take into account.
You have to make sure that
all of your schema objects
were converted successfully.
You need to plan for
functionality testing.
So you moved your database.
You converted your schema.
We'll talk about schema
conversion in a moment.
You want to run a representative
test of your applications,
of your current
application workload,
on the target database to see
that nothing breaks, right?
You want to make sure you
plan for data validation.
So, as you move your data
from your on-prem environment
to Cloud SQL, you want to
make sure that all of the data
has been replicated
successfully.
And we'll talk about
those steps in a moment.
This is just
understanding what you
need to do for you
to be successful
and planning for that.
You need to do
performance testing.
Even if your applications are
fully compatible with Postgres,
just switching the JDBC driver,
and everything will run fine,
you're only using NC SQL
syntax, so no propriety Oracle
joint syntax, or
all-up functions,
or none of that stuff.
Even with all of
that, the queries
will behave differently--
different databases,
different query optimizer.
The execution plans will change.
And queries that might have
behaved in a certain way,
maybe using indexes,
might suddenly
switch to full
table scans, right?
So you have to make sure you
plan for performance testing
as well.
It's super important.
You have to also plan
for integration testing.
So as I mentioned, a
database is not in vacuum.
It doesn't exist in
vacuum, because in addition
to the application,
you might have
dependencies on other
databases, or other technologies
in your organization using
Oracle Database things,
or application-tier
integration APIs
that need to query multiple
databases at the same time.
So you have to plan to
make those tests as well.
And, again, the
same tests that you
have to do on the
database level,
you also have to do that
for the application, so unit
testing, performance
testing, integration testing.
Again, and plan for all of that.
That's your success criteria
for migration right here.
The next step would
be to actually
start getting your fingers
dirty and actually starting
doing the migration itself.
That normally starts from
the environment setups.
You have to kind of create
the target environment in GCP.
That means that you have to
first convert your schema.
And that's a hot potato, because
we can detect, using migVisor,
for example, a
lot of proprietary
features you're using.
We can surface those details.
We can give you tips
on what you have to do.
But you'll still need to
actually perform the migration.
So you have to leverage
different APIs,
convert your stored
procedures, convert
your materialized views, for
example, your partition tables,
all of that stuff.
Now, there are tools,
such as ora2pg,
which is an
open-source tool, that
can help you automate a lot of
the schema conversion process.
Depending on the complexity
of the source database,
the success rate,
from our experience,
go anywhere from like 30%,
40% automatic conversion
to sometimes even 60% and 70%.
But it's never 100%.
So for the schema
conversion piece,
leverage automatic
tools such as ora2pg.
But you'll also need to put
some elbow grease into it.
You have to put some
manual, honest DBA
work to kind of convert some
of the more trickier schema
objects, some of the more
trickier stored procedures.
So that's schema conversion.
It's part of your
environment setup.
Before you move the data, before
you test your application,
you need to make sure you have
a fully converted source schema.
The second aspect
is, well, you'll
have to deploy your
Cloud SQL target.
So you have to understand
what's the configure-- what's
the sizing that you
want your Cloud SQL
target to be comprised of?
So how many CPUs cores?
How much memory?
What's the IO requirements?
If you're a breaking one Oracle
database to multiple Cloud SQL
instances, you also have
to keep that in mind.
So you have to
size intelligently.
That's what we always say.
And you can reference--
I would say, as a tip,
reference the workload
you have on your Oracle database
and not the physical hardware
configuration as your baseline.
That's because cloud
economics for scaling
are different from
on-premise economics.
And we see, a lot
of times, we have
these big, monolithic Oracle
databases running on--
which have been over-deployed.
So an organization bought a very
high-end, super capable server
with hundreds of CPU
cores, terabytes of memory,
just in case, because
they know that they
might need to scale up.
They know that they might need
room to grow in the future.
So they have over-provisioned.
Not all of the databases
are like that, but many are.
And because it's very easy
to scale up when you move
to cloud-native technologies,
we would encourage you,
based on our experience, to
look at your actual workload,
such as the number of active
sessions in your database,
instead of physical CPU cores--
the actual physical reads
from your storage tier,
instead of the IOPS and
throughput capacity of your,
I don't know, like
NetApp or storage machine
in your organization.
So base your sizing on workload.
And again, we try
to kind of show
this information-- some of it,
at least-- in migVisor as well.
And then you also deploy your
actual Google Cloud targets,
which includes, say, Cloud SQL
for Postgres for the database,
but also compute engines,
VMs, for your applications,
because you know, you're going
to test your applications.
They need a virtual
machine to run.
So you also have to
kind of do that as part
of your environment setup.
When it comes to
schema conversion,
again, I've kind of talked
about it in a previous slide.
But some tidbits
here when it comes
to moving your different
database objects that you might
have in your current schema
right now from Oracle
to Postgres-- some
of the challenges--
and you'll have
access to this slide,
to this stack, so you can
kind of reference that later.
But for example, object
identifiers-- so Oracle,
basically, if you're
using quoted identifiers,
it converts it to uppercase.
And Postgres converts
them to lowercase.
So this can break your SQLs.
And less code, right?
But we see quotes
and identifiers
in a lot of the
queries generated
by certain applications.
So that's one thing that
can kind of cause pain when
it comes to schema migrations.
Database links, which we
talked about-- so Postgres has
an extension, Foreign Data
Wrapper, that can give you
equivalent database link
functionality in the database,
right?
That's not supported
in Cloud SQL right now.
So you have to
keep that in mind.
Maybe for certain
databases that are heavily
relying on database
links, you might
be better off with
Postgres on Compute Engine
or moving some of that logic
to the application tier.
Again, partitioned tables-- so
Postgres 9 has some limited--
does not have declarative
partitioning support.
It only provides
table inheritance,
which is not equivalent.
What Oracle does
is partitioning.
Postgres then adds the support
for table partitioning,
some of the Oracle partition
types, not all of them.
Postgres 11 expands
that a bit further.
But again, keep that in mind.
Sequences-- so you
move your database.
Sequence values will
have to be created.
So you might have
sequences right now
that have their values.
So sequence A might be
at a value of 10,000.
Sequence B might be currently
at a value of 256,091.
So when you create the
sequences in the target,
you have to make sure
that you actually--
when it comes to the switchover,
you rethink your sequences.
You advance them manually
to their current state
in the source Oracle database.
Again, these are just
some of the challenges
you have to keep
in mind, even when
you're doing a lot of
this schema conversion,
using tools such as ora2pg.
There is stuff that you
have to do manually.
Triggers are also
different, right?
So a trigger in Oracle is both
the event invoker as well as
the logic.
So you create a
trigger and a table.
The trigger will
actually fire once
when you insert a row,
for example, once per row.
And it also contains the logic.
In Postgres, it's different.
You have the trigger itself,
which calls a function.
So again, just kind
of keep that in mind.
Some other aspects--
I don't want to go
through all of that.
That's a lot of
the nitty-gritty.
But there are aspects when
it comes to schema conversion
environment setup that you have
to kind of take into account.
By they way, this is all kind
of surfaced in our product.
But we thought it would be nice
to show some of those bigger
challenges in the slide deck,
such as using views instead
of virtual columns, local
temporary tables instead
of global temporary tables.
Temporary table
behavior is different.
So keep that in mind as well.
Reverse key indexes
are not supported.
Bitmap indexes
Synonyms, you have
to use views instead.
So again, keep all of that in
mind as you do the migration.
There are data type differences.
Again, this is a--
it's boring.
It's nitty-gritty stuff.
But keep that in mind.
Not all data types
are supported as-is.
Even Oracle LOBs-- if you
move them to the BYTEA data
type in Postgres, it has
a 1-gigabyte limitation,
require API changes.
So again, keep that in mind.
And it's very-- now you see why
it's important to of surface
all of those details before
you actually start migrating,
because you want
to choose-- maybe
for the first database
you move to Cloud SQL,
you want to choose a database
that's, I would say, easier
to migrate and not necessarily
your most complicated database
in the organization.
Some other stuff, such
as certain changes
in how you invoke functions,
certain changes in the SQL
dialect.
You'll have access to this deck.
Just some tips, lesson
learned from migrations
we have previously done.
But again, it's just kind of
surfacing the challenges when
it comes to schema migrations.
A couple of things
about stored procedures
I want to mentioned briefly--
so Postgres 11-- sorry,
Postgres versions 9 and 10
only provide functions
instead of packages
and stored procedures.
That's a challenge.
Again, you have to
create functions
instead of stored procedures.
Postgres 11 finally adds a
CREATE PROCEDURE statement.
So that's super cool.
However, invoking functions
and procedures are different.
So you need to change that
syntax in your application.
And packages that
are not supported.
So you need to use
schemas in Postgres
to group certain procedures
or functions together.
Certain Oracle PL/SQL
control elements
are also not supported.
So again, a lot of
stuff to take in.
We don't have time
for all of that.
But just keep that in mind when
you do your schema conversion.
And again, reference this deck.
And you can use our product
for some other information
that could be-- can save you
a lot of pain in the future.
So Postgres 11,
Postgres 10 and 11
also brings a lot
of improvements
when it comes to Oracle
compatibility versus Postgres
9.6, such as enhancements
of parallel queries.
Again, this is a
very nice slide.
I kind of cherry picked some
of the features which I think
are most applicable when
it comes to migrations.
I kind of cherry picked those
and put them in one slide,
so you can have
it as a reference,
because Postgres 10 and 11, they
have a lot of functionality.
Some of it is specifically
relevant for Oracle-to-Postgres
migration.
So enhancements in parallel
query, such as parallel
merge join, such
as parallel index
scan-- these are things that
the Oracle optimizer knows
how to do.
And now, Postgres knows
how to do them as well.
We have full text search support
for JSON and JSONB data types.
We have additional
performance enhancements,
by the way, in Postgres 11,
such as paralyzed hash joints--
super important.
Covering indexes--
finally, right?
So that's another
Postgres 11 feature.
You can use CREATE
PROCEDURE, which
is the new syntax, not
available previous to that.
And you can call
using the CALL syntax
to invoke stored procedures
in your database.
But again, have this
slide as a reference.
Keep in mind that
Postgres 10 and 11
bring a lot of new
functionality that's
more equivalent for what
you might have right
now in your Oracle environment.
OK, and when you finalize
all the schema conversion
aspects, automatic
and manual, and you
want to deploy your Cloud SQL
instance, it's super easy,
like a few clicks in the
Google Cloud Console UI.
You can provision a
Cloud SQL instance up
to 64 cores and 416 gigabytes
of memory, which, by the way,
that's the limit for you.
So if you have an Oracle
database that has more,
you need more than 64 cores
or 416 gigs of memory,
you will probably
need to split up
this database and its workload
to multiple smaller Cloud SQL
instances in GCP.
If you're migrating Oracle RAC,
it's going to be a challenge.
There is no way to
do Active/Active
clustering in GCP right now--
in Postgres at all, by the way.
It's not just specific to GCP.
But there are
workarounds around that,
such as moving
some of that logic
into the data access layer, into
the application tier itself,
so that you can
actually maybe have
like a fleet of Postgres
Cloud SQL databases ready.
And then you can do the hot-swap
via the application tier.
You can also maybe send
application requests
using a queue, such
as Google Pub/Sub,
so that the data access layer
can, in case of failover,
take those requests
and route them
to the Cloud SQL instance
that will become available.
So there are some workarounds
about that as well.
Oracle Data Guard is going to
be a bit easier to migrate.
You can use Postgres
replication, which is natively
supported in Cloud SQL.
There are some challenges,
such as cross-region DR,
if you're doing that right now.
But again, it's much easier.
So RAC is going to be tricky,
require some application
changes if you want to
meet the same levels
of high availability.
Data Guard is a bit easier.
But again, keep that in mind.
It still needs to--
you need to know how to
leverage the right Cloud SQL
technologies to do that.
You'll need to
test for failover.
So before you actually sign
off on the new environment,
you have to test failover.
So once you
provision everything,
once you have your
replication set up,
once you have your high
availability set up,
you have to test failover
before you move your production
workload.
You have to see that it behaves
as you expect it to behave.
You have to test your backups.
You have to test how long it
takes to recover your database.
And you have to, of
course, configure
monitoring and alerting.
This is all part of
the environment setup.
And again it's super,
super, super important.
Other step-- now, I'm not going
to go into the next few steps.
A, I don't have a lot of time.
But B, there are other talks at
Next which cover these aspects.
There is a great talk from
Alooma about data replication
specifically.
I just want to
briefly mention that.
So data migration.
So after you've
provisioned your Cloud SQL
target, converted
the schema, it's
going to be a challenge, right?
You still need to take
care of moving your data,
copying your data from your
Oracle database to the cloud,
to Postgres.
There are a lot of tools that do
heterogeneous data replication.
So you can either use a
bunch of, like, ETL tools
that are available--
Informatica, for example.
You might be using Pentaho,
or Talend, or CloverETL.
There are a lot of--
some open-source,
some commercial tools
that can help you
move your data.
But you also need to
understand the concept
of CDC data replication,
which is Change Data Capture.
So if you're using an ETL
tool to move your data,
that's a one-time copy.
And that would require
downtime when moving your data
from your existing
Oracle environment
to Postgres, because
you move the data,
but data keeps changing.
If people keep working on
your source Oracle database,
data keeps changing.
So you will lose data
on the switch over.
And that's why
tools that perform
real-time CDC, Change Data
Capture-- kind of like they
read the Oracle, read
your logs, and they stream
the transactions to the
target in real time,
are often used when you
want to minimize downtime.
Heck, many of you might be using
products such as Oracle Golden
Gate right now, which is
a heterogeneous database
replication product from Oracle.
You can leverage that to move
data to Postgres, for example.
So there are a lot
of tools out there.
And there is a great
Alooma talk about data
replication at Next, which
I encourage you to attend.
But then again, keep
in mind the differences
between one-time loads
and real-time replication.
So again, I talked about
it in previous slides.
So I'm not going to reiterate.
But you need to make sure
that you take into account
both loading what you currently
have in your database,
as well as kind of how you're
going to plan and stream
changes to the target.
You'll need to test
your applications.
We talked about it, a couple
of points I want to mention.
So you have to stress test
your existing database--
sorry, your new
Cloud SQL database
and see that it meets your
performance characteristics.
You need to make sure that your
application workloads, SLAs
in terms of query performance
and query responsiveness
are met.
We talked about it, essentially.
But that's stuff you'll have
to do only after you migrated
the data, so only after you have
like a working copy of Cloud
SQL Postgres, for
example, with your data,
and the Compute Engine servers
for running your applications.
That's when you can
test your applications.
So that's, again,
something you have to do.
And also, keep in
mind that it might
be worthwhile to create a
reverse replication flow.
So in case you have to do
a rollback-- so let's say
you planned everything.
You execute everything.
Everything is great.
But then, after
you went live, you
found out an issue,
maybe an application
you did end up forgetting.
So you'll need to kind
of think about creating
a reverse replication
flow, just in case
you want to roll
back your changes
and move back to the
original Oracle database
until you work things
out, because otherwise,
if you just set up a
one-way replication process,
and you move to your
new Postgres target,
and you start working with the
changes applied to Postgres
would not be replicated
back to Oracle.
And it will essentially
be lost when you switch--
if you need to switch back.
Let's hope it won't happen.
But sometimes, it might happen.
So again, we talked
about all of that.
It's in the deck.
I don't have a lot of time.
So I'm going to go
briefly over that.
But again, we talked about it.
And it's in the
deck for reference.
So do application QA.
Make your application
behaves as expected, right?
Nothing breaks, and
performance is good.
Do query QA and database QA,
both on the workload side,
but also making sure
that you can failover,
that you can back up
and restore, the time
it takes to backup and restore.
So you'll know your IT's
setup as you need it.
So you test high availability.
You test DR. You allocate
time for performance training.
This is all part of the
migration validation step.
Compatibility of application--
we talked about it some.
Modern applications might be
more compatible with Postgres.
Legacy application might
not be as compatible.
So it's very important to map
the applications that connect
to your database right now.
Are they legacy?
Are they modern?
And they using the Oracle Call
Interface, custom drivers,
JDBC, ODBC?
Java applications would probably
be easier to port versus,
I don't know, C++ or
like COBOL applications,
some of the legacy stuff.
So you need to make sure
that your applications are
compatible.
It's also, sometimes
there is a difference
between porting
in-house applications
to third-party applications.
So if it's an application
you developed in-house,
you might have the
resources internally
to make the changes
needed to support
Postgres or MySQL if needed.
If it's a third-party
application, maybe--
and it's not supported, then
that's going to be a problem.
So map your applications
for compatibility
and identify specifically
legacy applications
that would probably
make your migration
a whole lot more complicated.
We talked about performance.
Bottom line-- switching
database engines,
queries will behave
differently, no matter
how compatible you
are and how much
do you think that you're
only using [? NSIS ?] SQL.
So plan for performance
testing as well.
We talked about rollback
strategy just a bit, right?
So create a reverse replication
flow for your data migration,
making sure changes are applied
back to the source database.
Sorry.
And keep your old
environment around
after you go live with
the new environment.
Keep the old environment around
for at least a few days, maybe
a few weeks, just in case.
Maybe you forgot there
was a script running
on the Chrome tab of
the Oracle database
that you forgot about, right?
So just keep it around,
because you might need it.
Again, this is
rudimentary stuff.
But we saw a
project where people
went live, closed
the old environment,
and then figured out that
they missed something.
[MUSIC PLAYING]